Francis is that damn talented he can hit
if I'm his coach I'm going caution the
win we're not training any technique
you're going to freaking Homer simps
this thing run at him like you did
against Rosen stro do that we're not GNA
try to be cute and sit back and pick the
stud forget your jab forget what you
what we're doing on the pads this is a
street fight if you sit back and you try
to outbox Tyson Fury he's going to
change your life and it's not going to
be good if you if this thing goes to
distance you will never fight the same
ever again he's going to box your brains
in we don't want that go out on your
Shield you in order to win Francis has
to get this done with pure chaos in two
rounds if this thing goes past two
rounds it's gonna get dicey and it's
gonna get ugly Tyson Fury is the best
heavyweight to ever put on those 10 o
gloves